in five four three two one
welcome everybody to another episode of
the genius brain podcast
I am your co-host David so and I am your
other Coco co-host
Joe Jitsu Kawa and today we have this
marvelous guest by the name of Kali
[Laughter]
marvelous guest Kelly boy yes hey man
there's a lot of words in a dictionary
we gotta use them or else they go to
waste
that's true you know what I was thinking
about the other day where Japan so so
when Joe and I were Japan we did this
samurai class this guy that was the
instructor he was one of the [ __ ]
funniest dudes I ever met in my life
like we didn't expect his guys to be the
way he was cuz you don't you like
samurai is supposed to be like very like
strong manly type of [ __ ] what she what
she was like compared to what we were
doing he was [ __ ] dope but the way he
would explain things was [ __ ]
hilarious like if he wanted us to do
something that was manly he would make a
manly voice and if he wanted us to do
something feminine he would do a
feminine voice it was if you have a
sword
don't be strong like a man like this but
don't be like a gentle girl like kind of
amount of energy into it I guess like he
it's he's a bitter actor but right yeah
the the the samurai school we went to is
like samurai theater mmm so they're like
basically what they were explaining is
the art of sword fighting and [ __ ] like
that after there was no need for
samurais samurais didn't have work so
then they got into theater oh that's
like for real for real huh yeah so they
they they have real techniques of like
fighting and [ __ ] and I was also like a
way for samurai to express themselves
like artistically oh yeah so then a lot
of those moves that we're learning that
shit's like real sword drawing samurai
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] I was falling asleep
because I was so exhausted you know it's
like what it's like
it's like um it's like a kung-fu show or
like wushu you know how I was like
supposed to be kung fu kung fu and it
turn into like theater or whatever oh
like a performance art yeah so that's
what we took at the samurai class I
should make this that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
fun though it was surprisingly fun how
long was it like what 30 40 minutes man
it felt fast I think they got to we got
to dress up in the whole garb and I do
we all look [ __ ] dope like I wish we
could dress like that on a daily only in
a winner though but it takes like two
people to put it on you though yeah you
cannot put that [ __ ] on by yourself
but you look like a boss man it's like
you got these big-ass skirt pants and
like this [ __ ] robe and and then you
walk around with a sword I just feel
like I look like something dude would
just like to Japanese hookers at me all
the time yeah by sucking my David how
heavy would you say that uniform was Oh
heavy as I thought it would be but it's
pretty huh the one that we wore was like
a cheaper lighter version like it's a
show version I wore an actual one hello
and I took photos with Jess yeah it's
pretty thick man it's layers - mmm it's
hot as hell and it feels like you're
wearing a male corset oh sure it's like
yeah it's tight yeah I mean cuz they
didn't have like belts I guess back then
so you just got a tie a bunch of [ __ ]
knots everywhere and because we did a
tea ceremony out there - yeah we had in
the uniform no in a different we dressed
up and yeah inside but those were like
the cheaper versions of it like the
lighter versions yeah cuz all the girls
kimonos were like they were like thinner
and like I don't know like the one that
just was wearing in a photo shoot that
was a legit one that [ __ ] looked crazy
yeah yeah did you guys go to you that
like puppet shows cuz I know like that
whole scene is so great I remember this
is a book I read called a master
puppeteer like a traditional puppet
change like the apprentice has a has to
do like - 20 years of just like moving
the leg I know what you're talking about
yeah when they do like Kabuki theater
kind of shares but with yeah
Japanese people in there [ __ ] like
meticulousness yeah man you know you
watch the Dreams of Sushi yeah is
[ __ ] that one guy well he opened up a
very successful sushi restaurant out in
Seattle it was one of his apprentices
who was bald
he [ __ ] I don't know what type of
emotional suppression like he had with
it but he's over there now he had the
[ __ ] red mohawk
oh no he's like one of the most
successful like zero yeah embrace the
Westerners yeah I do like I'm forgetting
the number but he was just cooking the
tamagoyaki the egg for like ten years
before she was what she sucked because
actually slowly take you about a year
but you just suck that bad dude I always
say like if you have OCD and and you
love ASMR [ __ ] go to Japan that's
perfect it's like if you get all of the
most clean freak OCD like hardcore like
perfectionist in the world like that's a
place for you I feel like each culture
fits a personality too mmm like if
you're kind of adventurous and
pioneering and you like to start your
own [ __ ] then it's like go to America I
think Korean people are Asian people who
think they're as clean as Japanese
people but they got Chinese people
habits great people are to be they like
the perfect mix between mainland China
and Japan geographically they're in the
middle - that makes sense do you know
even our like Buddhist architecture is
right in the middle it's like in between
Chinese and Japanese when I was in Seoul
- I had this I don't know it also feels
like there's a lot of American influence
in Korea - oh for sure yeah like the
military and all that but then the
culture is like now I feel like it's
Chinese Japanese and very American yeah
like it's very like entrepreneurial like
it's they I don't know I think
culturally to Koreans are more open and
like able to express themselves and say
things like it's like opposite of
Japanese yeah like Japanese people are
always like politicking I think I'm
saying it feels like a middle between
both right because I know Korean people
- they they definitely care a lot about
personal image like there's my friends
now till this day they're still scared
of their parents and what they think oh
yeah at the age of like 30-something
they still lie they
they hide things from their parents any
Asian country that's not even Filipinos
man Philippine will be breakdancing and
then they're like down to breakdance
don't you dance over here this is not
the place for you to dance okay you have
to be a nurse
I know RK RJ RJ are just lazy they don't
ever want to say the kids full names JIT
because the full names is probably like
Jason Ryan J RJ RJ come here so we're
gonna get into the topic today every now
and then we like to I like to go through
DMS people message the genius brain
thing and you know there's a couple of
stuff that people want to ask and I
thought this was very interesting um
they said four genius brain do you know
of anyone that had to cut off their
family for their own sanity and mental
health my family is notorious for
booting out do we cut out people people
run from us too it goes both ways man no
I think some people they try too [ __ ]
hard to hold on to family that is toxic
because they're like nah man
we're family we gotta [ __ ] do it but
there's just some people that you just
gotta get rid of man yep for me there
was I mean it's a whole long story I'm
gonna go too much into it
but there was a point I didn't talk to
my dad for a whole year so when I was
trying to be a stand-up comic and do
music and everything else like that my
dad and I did not get along number one
there could be a numerous reasons for it
and understandably I understand where he
comes from too because you know I wasn't
that great of a kid so maybe he was
trying to he was try to set up a future
for me but I didn't want to follow it
but what ended up happening was I would
snap at him he would snap at me I was
napping and he would snap at me and I
remember at a certain point I felt so
[ __ ] defeated I just asked my mom
what am I supposed to do around dad like
how do we get along cuz as of right now
like I feel he hates me and I hate him
she does you know what just you need to
talk to him in a calm manner speak to
him kindly and just say yes just for now
while you live under his house just say
yes I said
cool I'm gonna try this out so and you
gotta fight every 30 so this [ __ ] out so
this is was like my last straw so I
basically basically what happened was I
I went to Bible study came back but when
I left the Bible study I I broke this
door it was like I lived in this in the
back in the backyard in this shed area
we call it the shed but it was actually
just a separate house area that that's
where I lived my dad built that so I was
living there but it was so hot this
summer II was like 110 degrees at the
wood kind of warped and it locked me in
the in that room so I had a break out
and so the lats bro - cool a man who
lived in the backyard shack yeah
basically we call it the shed but the
shed it wasn't really [ __ ] that it had
AC head so it's like another hope with
that house yeah okay yeah and so I broke
that [ __ ] and I went went out and I kind
of just left it there I mean I had
nothing I mean what can I do and it was
in the yard and the yard skated out so I
came back and my dad got home before I
did and he goes why the hell did you
break the door below about what were you
thinking and I was like okay dead and
and he called me and I told him was like
hey I'm really sorry I'll explain to you
when I get back but I'm a Bible study
right now so can you just wait and he
starts screaming at the top of his lungs
and I was just like the [ __ ] that
hour-long cell he's not working you know
and I was like I'm sorry I said started
multiple times and I said I'll be back
and we'll talk about it so I come back
home and the first thing he did was like
he called me he was like why are you so
stupid is what he said and I looked at
him and so years ago I had a
conversation with them I told him to
stop call me stupid I was like if you
call me dumb one more time like I will
literally leave and you will never speak
to me ever again
and that's the thing my mom always told
him was to never call a stupid and can
he call me stupid again
yeah and that [ __ ] [ __ ] enraged me
and I was like that means he's stupid
because he didn't even want to listen so
he's he's so interesting because I he
goes like I remember him yelling he goes
like wow he was when you need help
why don't you just call me I was like
dude I was locked in that place the AC
was but I would've died we're not
talking about right and and I remember
because I was just trying not to yell so
I was just staying calm because I was
trying take my mom's advice so you
didn't even get to explain that you
couldn't get out I couldn't explain it
he was just like yelling at you yeah
how would you do that Bubba I was like
well the door he just kept yelling over
me yelling yelling yelling yelling and
then we got into this whole fiasco where
basically he got so confrontational I
actually just [ __ ] shut past him and
I and I literally are glass door I
[ __ ] like Muay Thai taped that [ __ ]
and his [ __ ] collapsed it fell
forward I went to the back once and I
grabbed my [ __ ] and I laugh at this age
you're already too big so he couldn't
beat your ass yeah he I was just too big
but you know I I never ever fought back
so it's like you would [ __ ] his
perimeters yeah punch the wall oh you
have terrible hand eye coordination my
face all right you missed me again [ __ ]
yes so basically what happened like just
to keep that long story short I left we
had we had a point where I talk to him
and I was like hey man like you you were
I told him he was wrong I was like you
were wrong right but he's never wrong
yeah and my mom knew he was wrong and he
was wrong and he couldn't control his
temper he was yelling at me he called me
dumb and you know my mom knew she was
really upset at him and I say stupid in
Korea well he called me [ __ ]
oh come she hope yeah I've heard that so
[Laughter]
I remember cuz he was I he after I left
and I came back I went to get some more
of my stuff he was just screaming in the
room and I you know I was outside the
his door and I was just standing there
and I said to when he finally quieted
down I was like and when I said to him
verbatim was if you are telling me right
now you didn't do anything wrong
since the day I was born you've never
messed up once in your life that you and
I can never have a relationship right
and then he said I've never done a
single thing wrong to you and I that's
already wrong in the statement it was
like a posit and he said that was like
cool and I literally grabbed my [ __ ] and
I left I didn't talk to him for a year
my mom was like bawling and whatever but
he just wouldn't admit that he was wrong
and that was like a point I can talk to
Hubbard and Doug yes stubborn and so why
are pastors so stubborn ancient Asian
dad pests are so [ __ ] stubborn it's
like he's not like that anymore it has
to do with either his youth or something
it could be just frustration from other
stuff
[ __ ] [ __ ] money mm-hmm definitely
raising two [ __ ] crazy ass what crazy
kid well yeah he that's why your
brother's he's little angel my my dad my
mom I remember my mom had a conversation
with my dad and I found this after the
fact but my mom told me that he had a
conversation with him where he had this
dream where he wanted his family to be
in one household because he grew up in a
broken household too because he but he
broke the house so my mom would say that
she goes you should feel bad for your
father because he's probably one of the
saddest human beings I've ever met oh
you mean I was like because he grew up
in a broken household his house wasn't
that great right but at the same time
because he well he doesn't want that to
happen he's trying to keep you guys as
close as possible but because he's doing
that he's pushing you away so it's it's
too thirsty so it's he says she's it's
very sad
yeah it's trying to keep you all
together because he wants this family
unit but because he's doing that he
won't let you breathe so he's pushing
you away and he wants to hold on to you
so hard
so she says feel bad for him I was like
I I do feel bad for him but at the same
time how when I'm being abused you can't
call me stupid and expect me to stay
around I said she talked to him she goes
you know you have arguably number one
she goes your if you wanted him to be
this Korean Korean kid
we should have lived in Korea hmm why
did you move us here see was that was
your choice
you chose to raise a Korean American kid
if you wanted a Korean Korean kid where
you live in this household and there's
generational family stuff then we should
have stayed in Korea so you have to live
with that choice so David's an American
kid what did you want damn
my mom said the same [ __ ] dude you're
not smart yeah and so she she and I
think that kind of hit my dad a little
bit he goes oh David he's not gonna be
the kid that I want him to be I'll say
of course not like what did you think
and and so at that point he even
apologized after a year you know how I
came back into the house he calls me up
he goes I have a new puppy what you want
to tell you apologize little black and
white water you say sorry yeah
jasmine yes I went to go see the puppy
and we play with the puppy and then he
was just like she should probably just
move back in
you should probably still gotta be an
advices yeah you guys watch oh my back
in I cleaned up the shed it's nice that
you can just move back in there I was
like is he saying sorry alright baby
steps baby way to be are you past the
point of like asking your father like
how it was for him cuz if your mom had
to explain to you what it was for your
father for him to open up that
conversation to might be a little
overwhelming but I mean oh I know what
it was like cuz we had a I end this
before where we had a huge fight where
he actually opened up and told me it was
our last fight ever it was like four
years ago so he our last fight he
basically opened up I said you know what
like you want this I feel I want to have
a relationship with you like the way you
he said that yeah cuz I told him I told
him I was like what sir basically we got
into it this thing when I told him like
why can't you just talk to me like a
person I was like I call our mom two
three times a week because we just talk
hey what are you doing yeah oh I'm just
doing this [ __ ] blah blah blah we joke
around you know every time you call me
it's what are you doing are you doing
this right are you doing this wrong yeah
why can't you just talk to me like a
person you're the one who wants to be
close to me but I haven't had a
conversation with you ever right and he
just goes you goes you know I can't do
that because my parents didn't talk to
me like that my mom didn't your but your
grandma your grandpa didn't talk to me
like that I didn't talk to them like
that I had a girl by to take care of
them so for me this is how I communicate
it's the only way I know how to sew I
say you're trying to change me you keep
trying to change me and making me into
this new guy but I can't this is how I
am so I'm at this point I'm 60 years old
who are you trying to change because you
should be at the point where you're
trying to understand me and change for
me I was like oh [ __ ] you know and I was
like you should understand this is how I
communicate so how come you can't do the
same thing back for me and I was I oh
[ __ ] he kind of got my ass there mm-hmm
and so now I just oh [ __ ] and I kind of
was like oh I get it now but it's cool
cuz he's kind of mini to fall like [ __ ]
it's hard man yeah I've been talking to
people like like a [ __ ] leader yeah
so what did you expect that that's him
just saying I'm concerned for you yeah
right he's like hey little [ __ ] how
come you [ __ ] post this yeah
nobody goes so you know that YouTube
video mmm you don't think you're
uploading enough like how good if I
could kill you yeah it's like annoyed
he's like you know but that's his way of
saying like Oh is everything all right
because you're not posting yeah are you
making enough money yeah do you need
help that's like my mom sushi we have a
rule I made a rule that I was like you
are not allowed to ask me about YouTube
stuff because you don't know it and I
don't know how to explain it to you so
stop asking right but without fail two
minutes later you should probably post a
video right now I have one for you yeah
we transfer that's like the only mommy
there's others too but that's like the
main time I had like cut my dad out yeah
that that's really amazing that your
father but you didn't really you took a
break yeah right you didn't really cut
them out no i-i've don't know if I'll be
able to cut cut family out like I'm not
like that though well you don't have
shitty family yeah I mean they help they
would have to do some some [ __ ]
terrible I get like oh I
okay I had in-laws that we know a lot of
my cousin's just don't allow back into
the family anymore because rapists oh
that's pretty bad but no we don't have
any of that so he told us on a podcast
about his uncle who has a little bit of
issues hello everybody this podcast is
brought to you by audible listen up
Amazon Prime members for a limited time
you can start an audible membership and
save 66% on your first three months a
total of $30 off that's not getting
three months for the price of one and I
know you love deals you'll pay just for
ninety five per month for the first
three months after that it's only
fourteen ninety-five per month the offer
is valid from July 1st all the way
through July 31st 2019
now audible members get a credit every
month good for any audiobook you are
store regardless of price and to audible
originals uh new
credits do roll over now if you don't
like an audio book exchange it for free
plus your audiobooks are yours to keep
forever even if you cancel there are no
commitments you can cancel any time now
for me one of the audiobooks that I'm
listening to is Rich Dad Poor Dad Rich
Dad Poor Dad teaches you about financial
financial financial literacy and on top
of that it teaches you how to invest
your money and invest your money into
proper things now for me if you guys are
wondering if I have listened to this
before of course I have my friends you
guys already know I've invested my money
to a lot of these businesses that have
worked out well and have been working
great for me and actually started with
this audio book it's pretty awesome guys
so on top of that audiobooks and audible
originals members get access to audio
guided fitness and meditation programs
so visit audible.com slash GB or txt GB
to five hundred five hundred to get
started two-day visit audible.com slash
GB or txt GB to five hundred five
hundred to get started today my friends
get at it you'll love it and listen to
those lovely audio books there's
multiple like I think multiple things
happened in my family like we had a very
toxic abusive family and people were
like talking [ __ ] behind each other's
backs and all this stuff right and then
we found the root of the problem what
was happening is a couple of our in-laws
um there was this one in-law okay so um
my cousin's married to this - her
husband he's not our blood right and in
his older brother married this girl
who's problematic and she caused she
stirred up [ __ ] at the church he's just
one of those people that are constantly
conspiring finding [ __ ] about other
people being like frenemies or best
friends with women and then like getting
all this [ __ ] and then it's almost like
high school just never left his [ __ ]
and it went she's just Searcy right and
and so once we found that out because
sometimes a lot of my cousin's they're
like very very
what's the word like they're they're the
type of people that are like if
something's going on with you I got your
[ __ ] back oh I'll stop whatever I'm
doing and taught and listen to your [ __ ]
for five hours yeah
comes to find out that someone a lot of
this stuff was just [ __ ] and it's to
get into their good side so they could
get trust and then she would go out and
spray all this [ __ ] at church and like
all kinds of crazy stuff and we're like
what the [ __ ] like we never had anything
this bad in our family the worst that we
had was physical violence yeah and and
so but this conspiring rumor [ __ ] was
like we got a kid we got to stop this so
then they basically told them you're not
allowed to come to any of our gatherings
that we don't want to see you hoes [ __ ]
and our family started to get better and
then that was like okay it's a purge
homie like we gotta go me it's game over
there were so many interventions the the
next coming years that it was like
what's awesome is that we gave everybody
I was a kid back then but they gave
everybody an opportunity to change yeah
and to talk and to and to be vulnerable
with each other and be open with each
other and all this stuff right and then
it came down to my uncle and your uncle
sounds very similar to your dad horrible
childhood never [ __ ] wrong pastor so
he's got a lot of power
he talks at you doesn't talk with you
and all kinds of [ __ ] but this fool is a
violet [ __ ] he beat all of us up
he beat me up like harder than my own
dad right and they confronted him and
they said if you are a stubborn dog and
you keep like being aggressive I don't
want that energy around my kids
they threatened him like I'll never let
you see my kids yeah and then so he had
to just bite his [ __ ] tongue and start
talking and listening and changing he's
still a stubborn piece of [ __ ] but
better but he's not aggressive anymore
yeah he's very loving and um yeah that's
good yeah but also everyone grew up so
he couldn't he couldn't beat anybody
anymore
oh yeah yeah that's [ __ ] crazy dude
yeah so but that day and in so like
after that I think a lot of great should
happen to the family for we had a long
stretch of time of Awesomeness and then
recently you know [ __ ] went down like
some of my cousin's up and left and and
there was [ __ ] cheating and all kinds
of [ __ ] and I'm like man it's so crazy
cuz I thought we were living this dream
family like we just got over the crazy
[ __ ] yeah we're living this [ __ ]
awesome life together and every year we
would have family like gatherings at
[ __ ] what's that
snow summit nos not snow summit uh no
it's in up north everyone goes there
mammoth madness so we would rent out a
[ __ ] cabin right and the whole family
would go there we go fishing we would
just spend like four days just talking
about everything catching up and then I
[ __ ] missed that [ __ ] man but you
know we don't get to do those anymore
because some [ __ ] got stirred up with
divorces and stuff so people were we're
not able to maintain their relationships
because they were also not being there
being vulnerable individually yeah but
not with their relationship you know so
man it just keeps [ __ ] up but the
cool thing is we got rid of a lot of
that crazy toxic [ __ ] yeah so this now I
think is just normal drama like normal
like people that's really big nation
yeah yeah yeah but there's no conspiring
and lies and [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] cuz i
know i mean i don't know for this girl
like what was going on in her life um
but for sure it's hard to like cut out
family right because everybody says
blood is thicker than water
not if they're molesting you that's a
t-shirt is our man like we we we always
want like you even hear stories about
kids who were like you know sexually
assaulted by their parents right and in
their mind because their parents they
still can't break that mold of this
person the villain they know it's hard
man if they think that they're doing
something wrong by not allowing them to
touch them or something and you know i
keep reading these accounts or and even
hear it from certain people they go they
keep looking at themselves like Oh am i
doing something wrong
yeah maybe something's wrong with me
but when you like in your case when you
guys literally cut that poison out it
everything started better it was awesome
dude
but I know that the the bond with family
is so strong no matter how [ __ ] shitty
the parent is cuz one of my best friends
like his dad was a wife-beating [ __ ]
alcoholic like this [ __ ]
III was scared to sleep over his house
because my dad never he was violent
toward this us but not to this extent
yeah to him to his wife like it was
psycho level it was scary so I was I was
sleeping over and then this was smoking
inside the house with kids around like
yelling [ __ ] yelling out his wife and
I started [ __ ] shivering in my bed
oh man that fool came in reeking of
alcohol and he started petting me and
he's like sorry did I scare you that I
scare you and his wife comes in he's
like let him sleep and then he's and
she's crying and [ __ ] and he goes down
to my buddy's bed and then he [ __ ]
goes in and spoons him and he goes I'm
sorry baby did I did I scare you and
he's painting his head just drunk as
[ __ ] the whole room smelled like [ __ ]
alcohol and cigarettes [ __ ] and in in
the middle of him doing that and his
wife has just let him sleep just let him
sleep
and he goes shut up [ __ ] up and he
gets up and he smacks her and [ __ ] I was
like [ __ ] dude he's like yeah you keep
smacking the lady and then it's just
[ __ ] weird man like he would just go
[ __ ] nuts out of nowhere like you I
remember one time we were going to Sea
World and he bought us all burgers and I
in the backseat I was like damn that
[ __ ] was this is good right and they my
friends like yeah man I haven't had a
burger this good it's way better than
McDonald's and he was like shut the [ __ ]
up it's just a [ __ ] hamburger yeah
and I was we just we just [ __ ] looked
at each other like wow what a beautiful
day it's just life [ __ ] how much you
[ __ ] talk about how good the [ __ ]
hammer is it's just a [ __ ] hamburger
Homer you said all this in Japanese the
funny thing is this was not even
Japanese he's he's Chinese and I've
never met such a angry I got all
Japanese dads were angry as [ __ ] like
this
because it's normal in Omaha junkie
[ __ ] know how to speak up in
Japan oh I think he got picked on a lot
he's Chinese but grew up in Japan but
yeah so so okay despite all of this
right I knew this guy was a horrible
[ __ ]
he cheats on his wife all this crazy
[ __ ] right and his wife is just so
accommodating and she just she's just a
punching bag and I love his mom to death
then this fool dies early cuz you know
from he gets lung cancer in the moaning
he just gets sick and he dies like
really early man like late 50s or some
[ __ ] like that we go to his funeral and
my friend is just bawling like he's just
he can't contain himself he's crying
like crazy and I'm just like damn dude
that's nuts
cuz I would have been like happy that's
cool think I'd cry for my father the way
that he cried for his dad yeah so there
maybe there was a lot of great things
that was going on that I didn't see I
mean I feel too you know when that
happens people just recollect all the
good stuff yeah yeah exactly all the
best stuff at that moment isn't there
you know yeah yeah it goes back to like
just that just reminds you the funeral
like cuz talking about the toxic pool
that your family's not going through any
more like it's just like the normal
drama but I'm in my stage right now I am
in the thick of that you know so let's
talk about that man do we have 40 days
to talk - you guys already talked about
a lot of it not on this just like on
just you know we've lived together for
like six seven years I am a curious
[ __ ] gel I'm getting mentally
constipated just thinking about it but
just like going back to your friend just
grieving it reminds me of like me trying
to accept the relationship that I have
my father now it was alive you know but
I am grieving my therapist was like
you're going through the stages of grief
yeah because you set these expectations
and now you're finally in the stage of
acceptance realizing that you'll never
have that father that you've always
always wanted so you're at the point
where you realize your dad was a [ __ ]
loser
that's one
the hardest things to do yet when you
realize how [ __ ] dumb and like mm-hmm
sad it's it's almost pathetic right cuz
then we grow up thinking that our
fathers or parents yes the mountains and
they're like man my daddy does this my
daddy could beat up your daddy right you
know yeah I see my dad literally pull
this guy at the liquor store over the
counter because this guy kept telling me
to say [ __ ] you in Vietnamese and I was
like five six and you want to be that
guy that's like man I can't man I'm a
[ __ ] product of this dude I came right
and um but once you realized what a
[ __ ] loser they are you're like oh man
that's a piece of meat man like well
that sucks yes it to my foot cause like
it's he wasn't like a total deadbeat
like if I found that tree in his
stitches i paged him he was there right
if I need to go to practice he was there
always always there but then like the
emotional his emotional intelligence was
just like so yeah bad the next stages
though is sympathy empathy cuz nobody is
a hundred percent conscious of what
they're doing
mm-hmm and in control of what they're
doing right so the intention man they're
just living on autopilot dude mm-hmm
and when you hear his story I think this
is this is what gave me comfort is when
I realized if my parents do better than
their parents as parents then they did a
good job
yeah we're just like a better iteration
generation you can't compare to other
people because other people have have a
different race different pace you know
like so if my dad never really had
parents so you know for him he's never
really had family because as soon as he
was born you know his his mom died
giving birth to him so he never had a
legit mother and then immediately so his
dad was a company executive so which is
my grandpa and he was busy with work and
he had 13 siblings so at that point he
had to remarry for like you know
everyone had to be married back then
because you know it's like you have to
look up we have to keep up with the
parents's and all this [ __ ] but the
person that my grandpa remarried was
already came with three children
hmm yeah and and so author a life like
he never really had the warmth and the
love from anybody and then he was being
paid by you know how like rich Chinese
kids today like they get sent by their
parents to America yeah I didn't they
get passed around to different homes
that take care of them that was
essentially what my dad went through mmm
so when I look back and I'm like you
know what I still had a [ __ ] dope ass
childhood and he tried his best cuz I
think he he finally had a family and I'm
like that was [ __ ] cool so when I look
when I look at that situation I'm like
alright cool even though you're a
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
you didn't make it worse for me right so
yeah he could have made it worse for me
but bounced yeah yeah yeah it's it's
it's interesting cuz yeah that's true
though because I think like for my
grandpa too like I don't I don't
actually know too much about my grandpa
but my mom knows the most about him and
everything that she said about him I
mean I'll be it he had I mean think I
live - he was like 90 something years
old but so he must been doing something
right for somebody to keep him alive
that long but he he typical Asian story
gambled all his money away or some [ __ ]
you know I mean like my dad was doing
really well lost all of his money
they went really [ __ ] poor and so my
mom was telling me that and I always had
to find out things to my Ted about my
went through my mom but my mom says like
she he is always trying to make sure
that we don't have the bad traits that
my grandpa had and so that's why I think
he was so hard on me specifically cuz he
would see a lot of similarities that he
saw in his dead in me yeah you know so
he would always try you wouldn't make
him mad it's like you're funny and my
grandpa's fine just [ __ ] funny just
trying to be all that's floating around
you know but he'll the really think is
my dad thought that I always trusted
people too much because I because that's
how my grandpa lost all his money your
dad trusted people too much exactly so
what the [ __ ] is he saying people I
think we always do this to where we
always project a lot yeah so you know I
always say that the quality said I
hating somebody else how they're saying
quality I hated myself yeah you know so
when I see somebody do something it's
not even when I give advice it's not
like I'm giving you advice I'm giving
advice to myself first it's like damn
do that because I know what it's like I
know I've done that [ __ ] I've been so
many [ __ ] times like I've definitely
got burned quite a few times now I make
sure that I try not to I keep my circle
very small and which is something my dad
told me since this is day one but I had
to get burned to learning that [ __ ] I
think we all do though yeah you know you
can't go through our life without
dodging any pain yeah so like if this
person is is talking about like oh
should I get rid of family it depends I
always say it depends on how much it
affects you you know cuz like it might
not be as Extreme as like you're getting
[ __ ] molested by this person which
obviously everybody should leave but it
could be as simple as like oh my aunt
always criticizes my career choice right
so you're very sensitive and then if
they go to family gatherings they're
like man I never want to talk to my aunt
again because she every time I see her
she's always like [ __ ] bitching about
you know me becoming a psychologist or
some [ __ ] like that yeah
and it's like yeah but that's not that
ik that's to me it's not worth cutting a
relationship over that but for some
people it is because it it like it's so
much like they're so sensitive to where
that whatever negative [ __ ] that the ad
says they're thinking about it for a
whole week so that they can't do
anything I feel like if that's if that's
one of the cases I'm not for this person
or anybody else then you feel like you
have to cut that person now that's
actually a more of an internal change
that you could do yeah you know you
learning how to have a thicker skin and
understanding how to not internalize
what people's opinions are or whatever
you know like and that's it to me I see
it as a learning opportunity so you know
it might be hard but that's almost like
running for everybody that gives you a
hard time
yeah there's a lot of personal
responsibility that it takes to to
really do that too so I know for a for a
fact I think a lot of college
specifically Asian students I know if
it's because of media whatever but
there's like this trend of like [ __ ]
Asian parents always trying to make me
do this it's like well my other flippant
perspective to that is like I know that
a lot of Asian kids get financial
support from their parents yeah a lot of
I know a lot of kids who aren't
don't get they don't when they're 18
they're grown up and they have to move
the [ __ ] on yeah so for me it's like you
can't have your cake and eat it too you
can't say mommy and daddy pay for my
college pay for my food my clothes my
car everything but let me live my life
the way I want they're not you're Santa
Claus so you if you if you want to live
the way you want to live but still take
everything but give nothing back to them
how is that fair for them you know I
mean I know still [ __ ] up that they
want to control your destiny
but your wanting to have your own
destiny while with with this free ride
so you have to make that choice you
could technically go to college find
your ways get financial aid do
everything else you know fig and get a
job while you go to school like other
people do but you don't want to do that
yeah but you just want to sit there and
say oh my parents won't let me do this
no you can you just have to stop taking
their money yeah yeah and those are
choices yeah it's not ultimatum you
could make it happen it'll be a harder
road and sometimes you've got a cut off
your parents temporarily yeah you wanna
if you want to make your own decisions
in life yeah and it cuz you got to cut
him off and you got to cut up you got to
cut off that paycheck too
yeah you got to cut everything off
because we know Cassie yeah she did this
you talk a lot easier she you know her
parents were very against her doing what
she wanted to do in life so she had to
go out and just like cut out that type
of energy and go out there and try to
make it on her own with and she did
amazingly well yeah but then she came
back and then you know remedied
relationships or basically she's in
contact with them again right like but
like I think that's it I think it's what
do you mean by cutting off cuz when I
say cut people off we're done yeah they
don't exist yeah they're dead to me yeah
but I do take breaks from people because
sometimes I need to take a break to to
think like is it me like is it me that's
not strong enough well I'm not looking
at it the right way yeah but I can't
think when they're pissing me off
hmm so that's a good point yeah so they
take a break and I would always say like
look at a person and see their core
traits and you try to look at it with a
clean mind because it's easy to see them
as evil when they're hurting your
feelings yeah I think brakes are
something that help a lot of people out
too because some
I'm just not even that person is doing
anything wrong yeah by your [ __ ] self
yeah
and in and you can't think when your
heads clouded with anger it's like that
pressure cooker yeah you think oh this
person's trying to [ __ ] be shady to
me this person's trying to bring me down
yeah or whatever but for most in most
cases people are saying [ __ ] because
they're concerned but they don't know
how to say it right yeah I just thought
it comes off the wrong way yeah because
they don't want to say I'm worried for
you because it makes them sound like a
little [ __ ] oh yeah yeah especially
Asian aunties oh yeah but you know
they're hella worried there they were
like are you paying your rent on time
are you okay you know but they're just
like you're not a doctor yet yeah that's
hard man I don't dad that's all cutting
off thing is a very hard thing for me
cuz I don't know if I've ever I don't
know who I've ever really just cut off
completely that I've known I always say
look at the court rates because if this
[ __ ] is just habitually evil
because there's people that get pleasure
out of destroying other people because
they're unhappy so they need to make
other people like they need to conspire
up drama and see other people get [ __ ]
up they instigate and do all that [ __ ]
that's the kind of evil that existed in
my family that we had a kick-out yeah
cuz that kind of [ __ ] is very toxic and
you can't you can't help those people
yeah I think it's just I think
personality like personal personality
kind of like for me too if somebody is
like that I'm probably gonna talk to
them yeah well you give them a chance
yeah but if it's repetitive yeah around
it first let it go and then after a
while take them to design like what's
your problem you know you should really
stop doing that like it makes me feel
this way
either that or you're being a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know to cut that [ __ ] out
and you know usually usually what
happens and you know when I have done it
people they tend to backpedal they go oh
no that's not what I know yeah oh oh
that's not what I was trying to cut I
gotta read I gotta reassess my game now
normally it just never happens again
because they're not they don't want that
comment around you you break some [ __ ]
around I just think it very
uncomfortable you know good I talked
about this guy who every time I went
back to Sacramento you would make it
this bill oh here comes mr. Hollywood
and I did take him inside like what the
[ __ ] your problem in like why the [ __ ]
do you always have to do
[ __ ] I was like when you got it they're
jealous yeah when you got a new job I
just congratulated you and I left it at
that every time I come back you gotta
say some [ __ ] so what the [ __ ] your
problem yeah hasn't said it's in time
and talk to him since I mean I wouldn't
tell I didn't cut him out he cut itself
out yeah so it's same thing with my
family it's like we either cut people
out or they run on their own you know
because of that I think everyone gets a
chance cuz I have this philosophy of
like you got to give people the
opportunity to change you know so you
can't just cut them off and ride them
off as if they're always gonna be this
piece of [ __ ] because I never told I
never told them like a what the [ __ ]
right yeah and here's an opportunity to
talk it out or maybe I got it wrong
yeah but then if they sit there like a
cow or to be like no no no it's cool
it's cool and then they never see me
again
yeah I know what what happened they got
caught and they're ashamed
did you ever cut anybody out me uh no
I'm like in this actually you just said
you'd like that was actually my question
that I sent in wait so your uncle's a
rapist no it's very much like it's just
now that you know just going over 30
years old and like after my grandma
passed away I realized this image of my
family wasn't what it was yeah you know
this you know and so like the lives
where it was the glue that kept his
family together and so like I'm melting
that glue and realizing how [ __ ] up
everything was and like learning about
people and then at the same time I'm
learning about that and my father's
learning about that Oh your dad didn't
know well my dad I mean he knew but he's
like not that the my grandma's gone it's
a whole new responsibility for him yeah
she was so pale yeah she was a very she
cares yeah she was like the one you know
just don't cause me it's just like just
keep your mouth shut and just keep doing
this as long as we can and then the kids
always find out later because you know
the dolt probably all know and yeah yeah
right so like just with my my uncle each
is a registered sex offender
just a registered sex pain known as a
sex offender but um it's just like it's
just this weird protection because also
I think I mentioned the other podcast
that my he's still trying to be
protective
they're so try to protect this and treat
them like the Catholic Church man yeah
it's a hot ass daughter keep them cute
keep her away or a hot outside that's
what's what's going on currently right
now I mean it's not like oh my god he's
the devil there's a lot of [ __ ] sex
offenders and it depends on what
deteriorate right yeah like is he
kidnapped being women and [ __ ] raping
and killing them no like I don't know
like or did he just like do something
state a 17 year overall yeah I mean
there's different levels to it so but
also is just about like if the family
knows then they can also help him mm-hmm
yeah instead of like ostracize him yeah
it's like a weird and because when you
say you you have to cut the person off
but to take a break so you can assess it
and see how if that person serves you
and that energy that you need yeah
currently because you're in your own
[ __ ] - yeah that's your other
responsibilities in your family or
whatever so I'm just trying I'm like
they I mean listening and thinking about
what my father and my auntie are doing
now to address this new situation now
that the patriarch is gone yeah
and I'm the son looking at my father
yeah who's now the 17 year old 18 year
old I see him as is he the oldest he's
the youngest my dad how come the
youngest doesn't take over I mean the
oldest he's the he's the director sex
offender but he's also drug addict oh so
he's not like yeah yeah the sad part
about it is that how how shitty is it
for your grandma that at that age she
still had to hold everything together
there's a certain point where age where
you was she supposed to pass that torch
right yeah the kids are supposed to take
over the adult responsibilities and
allow their parents to finally relax
Rex right yeah cuz you know that worked
but then your but your grandma is still
at you know - the day she passed she
still had to keep the peace and let me
try to keep everybody together right and
I should have passed on to the children
and they should have been able to allow
her to relax that makes me think about
how lonely did she feel me she had three
other siblings but it just made me
analyze it in so much curious and
regretful that I didn't ask my grandma
about it it's just like.how alone in it
did she go that the being lonely maid
forced her to distract herself which is
keeping it as tight as possible yeah
because she's a course right cuz my
grandpa cheated and left to Louisiana
yeah I started a new family so my
grandma was by herself in this house it
was just a church and that in her house
is it uh dad cider mom said dad yeah
damn yeah so that's that's true cuz
you're so sad you rather have toxic
people around you because you're so
lonely and you're talking with and
you're in the vet like you're in
Victorville like a Barstow there's
nobody there
exactly so it's like no offense but ya
know one up every one of us yeah you
want to make friends with cactus in a
role right now
exactly runners that we're playing ball
the other day and they're just kids kid
kid right
play ball this was like in his jeans he
had like the [ __ ] Pippins on and [ __ ]
yeah there's a little odd kid and we
play basketball in the way he shoes this
would lock his knees and just never use
anything but his arms we just launched
that [ __ ]
I was like man bro where you from man
he's like oh what'd he say where was he
from like Lancaster or like Palmdale
Palmdale Palmdale
yeah he's like I'm from Palm - I was
like oh man I knew I know you and them
designee gross oh my god that's good so
we allowed this kid to come play ball
with this right because we were just
shooting around I missed my shot he goes
whack first thing out of his mouth whack
whack but then he also was like who's
your top like five players right this
kids 17 he's like first off the bat
Magic Johnson magic I was like yo it's
kind of like 40 years old we don't know
his age he's oh I got it off the bat
Larry Bird yeah I
do that I gotta go cream and I was like
what are you doing
she's [ __ ] crazy 70 old kid would say
Magic Johnson Kareem like that's so like
I'd be washed and play he's like I saw
highlights Wow lazy dude oh yeah okay is
he trapped in the [ __ ] past I don't
know he never even went through yeah
Lancaster he just watches everything on
VHS tapes yeah yeah yeah how show is so
[ __ ] funny man
yeah well that time is up on that one
man so yeah time is up
yeah guys that concludes this episode
the genes brain podcast I hope that
helped you out if you you know whoever
asked that get rid of everybody be alone
[Laughter]
people are [ __ ] troublesome yeah
just be alone dude figure [ __ ] out yeah
but you guys could catch us on iTunes
the iTunes podcast that's not even what
it's called is it all right watch a
[ __ ] couple podcasts oh yes it's on
iTunes it's on iTunes or I give us that
five star it's modified Spotify make
sure that you guys share these podcasts
if these help you out remember these are
just conversations this is nothing like
I don't know same [ __ ] very specific
I guess we just kind of just shoot our
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that we realized and
things that worked out for us yeah yeah
so once again like I mentioned this
before um this is not direct advice but
nobody's really giving you like legit
advice these are just thoughts
take it or leave it just want to support
you on your journey yeah if you don't
buy what they don't get mad about it
just state why you think it's you have a
different opinion and then move on -
life's too short to be angry don't be
any all right yeah what can what can
they find you cleave me if I my
Instagram Cleef Boyd that's it
[ __ ] alright y'all see y'all next time
[Music]